my special is on Amazon it was recently
before that at Whole Foods only just me
there on in person it was actually on
Netflix as well when it was there
anybody could see it if they had Netflix
or if they knew a person I really don't
know why more than one person has
Netflix like I got my password from my
old roommate he had his from his parents
they get theirs from Kevin Bacon like I
don't know why everybody doesn't do that
you can give it five stars if you like
it you give it five stars if you don't
like it if you don't like it just think
about how many stars are in our galaxy
there's like a hundred billion so fives
real low you got me I got a one star
review once that I liked from a guy
who's like I don't know about these
jokes they might be good he talked too
fast I'm dumb and what I like about it
most I think is that it's more review of
himself than me he's like I don't know
about this but I do know about this and
tell you about some things I love I have
a girlfriend I don't have her she's not
in a cage of a free-range girlfriend we
have a long-distance open relationship
so what I'm saying is I know a lady just
got out of a relationship right now
probably uh got out that's a fun way to
say it like I was digging through the
wall with a spoon left a poster over the
hole nobody knows I'm gone mannequin
under a blanket cassette tape playing
snoring sounds I'm working on the movie
it's called Ferris Bueller's josh trank
redemption
it's a mash-up we're going on a new
mashup of the movies mash and up then
that one a balloon house flies over
Korea and that's all I have so far
love Kanye Kanye is a genius I think I
think he may be the world's dumbest
genius cuz rapping is brilliant
he's talking less brilliant do you guys
know how hard that is do you know that
rapping is actually more difficult than
talking it's like we can most of us talk
and not rap he can rap can't always talk
it's impressive he's like a dancer that
can't walk he's like The WB frog he's
like hello my baby hello ribbit wait you
were just I saw you
sometimes you'll be in a bathroom I bet
and somebody will knock on the door and
they'll say is someone in there and then
it's your turn what do you do you
probably say like God someone's in here
which lets them know 100% exactly what
they need is someone in there someone's
in here you can say that but did you
know you don't have to say that you know
you could say is anything literally
anything that'll let them know that
somebody's in there is anyone in there I
love you you could say something
meaningful you Billy who's entering in
their black lives matter you give us
some trivia is it in there the longest
sidewalk in the worlds in Tampa it's
four and a half miles this is the way
that a priest sings not sure why God
created everything in the universe
including all the musical notes and all
the musical scales there are at least
eight of them maybe twelve many octaves
but a church every Sunday like songs
that only have two notes
in fact it's mostly only one note then
there's a lot of suspense that gets
added because oh my god where's the
other end of the song gonna be
everything is going until the other end
of the day happens then there's only one
note what do I know I'm just a Jew our
songs are pretty lousy as well dreidel
dreidel dreidel same two notes would be
better if it was drilled Riddler little
dreidel you can yell that in the
bathroom doesn't have to be words is
anyone in there
they'll probably give you more time you
know find a new bathroom of their own I
think my favorite thing though to yell
in a bathroom would be a is anyone in
there no one's in here they're not gonna
be like hey you lied to me five stars
out of a billion thank you guys so much
[Applause]
enjoy your lives
you